Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Nando's in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
OK, slight problem.
Nando's is in the US, but
it's only in four places:
Maryland, Illinois,
Virginia, and Washington, DC.
Now, I'm in LA, baby.
I'm on the wrong side of the Mississippi.
But luckily I have a colleague
who is a Nando's enthusiast in Chicago.
She frequented Nando's
when she was living in South Africa
and is perfect for taking the US reins
for this episode of "Food Wars."
Don't do "Food Wars"
without eating breakfast,
I realize.
Yeah, I've made that
mistake several times.
In the UK, Nando's chicken
comes in three serving sizes:
a quarter of a chicken...
Medha: In the US,
Nando's standard chicken
comes in just two sizes:
there's a half a chicken...
Harry: A whole chicken.
Medha: Or a fourth of a chicken.
You can get a whole chicken in the US,
but only as part of a platter.
And we're going to weigh the whole chicken
to see which country's
chickens are bigger.
USA chicken, baby!
We can also get boneless thighs in the UK.
If you order these, they
come in a portion of four.
Our thighs actually come
as a portion of three.
So we got one, two, three.
♪ Chicken, chicken wings ♪
♪ They're my favorite thing ♪
♪ And I love to sing ♪
If you haven't already seen it,
look up "The Nando's Skank,"
which is a very pure
distillation of British culture
in the late '00s.
It's Ed Sheeran and Example rapping,
rapping about Nando's in a car park.
I don't know why.
And then he's just flexing his black card,
which I'm fuming about,
'cause, you know, Nando's black card,
they give them out to select individuals,
and it entitles you to free Nando's,
which I'm just so jealous of.
Also, bone to pick with that in general,
why do they always give the
celebrities the free stuff?
Because they're the
people who need it least.
They're already rich.
Sort a guy out, come on.
Cameraperson: But you are a celebrity now.
I'm not a celebrity.
Not yet.
Next up in the UK, we've got wings.
They come in four portions:
portion of three.
Medha: Our wings come as a serving of 12.
Harry: A portion of five.
Medha: Or a serving of 24.
Harry: A portion of 10.
Or a portion of 15.
If chicken on the bone isn't for you,
Nando's also offers chicken
in the form of burgers, wraps, and pitas.
In the UK, you can get these as singles
or as doubles.
We can also get our chicken wrapped
or burgered.
However, in the US,
there's no option to add double chicken,
which sucks.
It's like a little burrito.
Holy....
Don't do "Food Wars"
without eating breakfast.
I'm going to cry.
We're going to remove all the toppings
from the single chicken
burger and weigh it
to see how it compares to the US version.
So, we're gonna take out
the tomato and the lettuce,
just like Harry mentioned.
Which is good because tomato
does not belong on burgers
and never should.
On the side of your chicken,
it's pretty common to get
some chips at Nando's.
I'm excited for this episode,
because I can actually
call them chips for once,
as that's what they're
referred to on the US menu.
Suck it, Joe.
Medha: Suck it, Joe!
Joe: What did I do?
[all laugh]
Why is everyone telling me to suck it?
[laughing]
He's not even hosting this episode.
I've just gotta send for him.
[beep]
Chips in the UK come in
regular or large sizes.
The standard US sizes
are regular and large.
However, if you get them
as part of a platter,
you can get the bonus extra-large size.
Let's weigh the large fries
to see whose is bigger.
Maybe I should have used the bowl.
Oh, no.
I'm still going to eat these.
I don't care if they
touch all these gross....
Where is it?
OK.
I'm getting too good
at emptying brick chips
from containers.
So, our scale is just about
adequate for this one,
and a portion of large fries in the UK –
I said fries. Why did I say fries?
I'm being conditioned to saying fries.
That's right, buddy!
I heard you say fries!
This show is getting to me.
[beep]
A portion of large chips in the
UK comes to about 498 grams.
Medha: 150 grams.
What about the biggest thing
on each country's menu?
Well, in the UK, it's
this: the family platter.
It comes with two whole chickens,
five large sides,
and will cost you 43 pounds and 70 pence.
The biggest US item is the jumbo platter.
It includes two whole chickens
with two extra-large sides
for $52.99.
Let's take a look at some
of the nutritional standouts
from the Nando's menu.
If you were to get a standard meal,
it might look something like this:
half a chicken, a portion
of peri-salted chips,
and a portion of Macho peas.
In the UK, this will come to
a total of 1,228 calories,
which honestly isn't too bad.
There's also nothing
really alarming on that.
The only notable thing is that it contains
186.4% of your daily protein intake.
Over here it comes out to 1,124 calories,
which is actually a little
less than the UK's version.
Our chicken and chips are
actually a little less calorific
than the UK's, but for some reason,
our Macho peas are more calorific.
What's the sitch?
Already I can tell
there's a bunch of spices
and seasoning on the peas.
I'm thinking butter is involved.
Ugh, I hate peas.
That is not what I was expecting.
It does have a kick to it.
Based on the ingredients,
there's not really anything alarming
that we see in the US version either.
There's just a lot of sodium in it,
which is kind of expected
because of all the spices
and the seasoning that goes into it.
One thing to watch out for
is the basting flavor of your chicken.
Somehow, if you get your
chicken as extra hot in the US,
it adds 4,611 milligrams of sodium.
That's double your daily allowance,
just for the baste.
Joe: That's so much sodium.
Medha: That's insane.
What about the most calorific
thing on the UK menu?
Well, it might not surprise you to learn
that it's actually a whole chicken.
Extra hot is also the least
healthy baste in the UK,
with an extra-hot whole chicken coming in
at 1,299 calories.
However, a whole chicken actually isn't
the most calorific thing
on the menu in the US.
This is the Nandoca's Choice burger,
which is a butterflied chicken breast
and coleslaw in between garlic-bread buns.
Dude, a burger with
garlic bread for a bun?
That sounds so good.
That is a genius idea. Send me that.
One of these comes at 1,003 calories.
It looks like the main culprit here
is the garlic-bread buns.
On the US menu,
the garlic bread is the
most calorific regular side,
and it's the highest-cholesterol
side as well.
Kinda wanna try it.
It's not what you would expect.
It's not like US garlic bread.
That's a little strange,
as the UK's most calorific side
is actually the peri-salted chips.
These come in at 519 calories,
whereas the garlic bread is only 362.
What are you guys doing
to your garlic bread?
I think we're just making
our garlic bread tastier.
It feels like you're
trying to attack me, Harry.
Trying to attack the US.
We don't like that.
While the garlic bread may
be high in cholesterol,
it pales in comparison
to one item in that area,
which is the chicken livers.
One serving of these
contain 978 milligrams of cholesterol,
comfortably the highest thing on the menu.
More than triple your
daily recommended amount.
UK Nando's don't disclose
cholesterol content,
but they do disclose fat content.
The fattiest thing on
the menu is, once again,
the whole chicken.
One of these contains 54.4 grams of fat,
which is around 69% of
your daily allowance.
[whispering] Nice. Nice.
Medha: [whispering] I wanna try that too.
Harry: Nice.
Nice.
OK.
Unfortunately, Nando's doesn't disclose
the full ingredients list in the UK.
Same here. All we get are allergens,
and the allergen list
doesn't contain anything too alarming.
We reached out to Nando's
for more information
about the ingredients.
They told us that all their chicken meets
or exceeds USDA quality
standards and is never frozen.
They also grow their own
African bird's eye chilies
on farms across South Africa
for an authentic peri-peri spice.
One piece of information you can get
from the UK's FAQ page
is that the plant-based
Great Imitator wrap
might not actually be as
plant-based as it seems.
The baste and the tortilla
wrap used both contain shellac.
Now, shellac is also sometimes
called confectioner's glaze,
and it's a natural polymer
that's used to give things a waxy finish
and to trap in moisture,
but where does shellac actually come from?
Well, it's actually secreted
by female lac beetles
onto trees in India and Thailand.
This means it's technically
an animal product,
and although it can be gathered
without harming the beetles,
this is hard to achieve in practice.
Not nice.
It's worth pointing out one
other FAQ from the UK page,
which is that the UK Nando's
have explicitly committed
to never using chlorinated
chicken from America.
Chlorinated chicken's been in
the headlines a lot recently
because it's kind of become the face
of differing food standards
between the UK and the US.
It refers to the process of
giving slaughtered chickens
a chemical wash before they're packaged
and sent to consumers.
What do you guys have against
our chlorinated chicken?
JK. Joking. You're gonna see.
There's so many things against
our chlorinated chicken.
This is done to kill harmful
bacteria like salmonella.
Even the European Union admits
that it's unlikely to pose
any health risk to consumers.
But campaigners say that
it also allows farmers
to cover up lower production standards
throughout the chicken-rearing process.
The good news is that it's estimated
only 10% of US chicken
actually gets treated with chlorine.
So it's not a guarantee that
Nando's chicken in the US
will have been through the process,
but it's an interesting example
of the different food
standards in the UK and the US.
Chicken tastes pretty good over here, so,
it is what it is.
Here is everything you will only find
on the menu at a UK Nando's.
And here's everything you can only find
on the menu at a US Nando's.
Let's start with some chicken options.
Here we got the Sunset
Burger, which is currently,
I believe, exclusive
to delivery platforms.
This is a soft roll.
And then it also contains chicken thighs,
cheddar cheese, red pepper
chutney, mayo, and lettuce.
Next up, we've got Chicken Wing Roulette.
Now, what this is,
is 10 chicken wings of
varying spice levels.
The idea, I guess, is that you order
a plate of these for
yourself and your friends,
you all pick one or two,
and the loser gets blasted
with some extra-hot sauce.
Now, obviously we have
to try this ourselves.
So myself and our cameraperson, Laura,
are going to give this
a go and see who loses.
Laura: Are we doing this now?
Harry: I think we are.
Laura: All right.
OK that one looks...
yeah, you're going dangerous, aren't you?
Harry: I'm going for,
like, a menacingly red one.
Laura: Yes, you are. I'm going for
the less menacing-looking one.
Harry: Well, hopefully it's a red herring
and I've done this to deceive you.
Harry: Cheers.
Laura: Cheers.
Laura: Absolutely fine.
Harry: It was OK?
Laura: Yeah.
It is spicy. It's not,
like, blowing my head off.
I feel like mine's maybe hot?
But if that's extra hot,
then I'm, like, very underwhelmed.
Slight anticlimax.
I think Laura maybe
just got, like, a medium
or a plain one, because
she was not fazed at all.
I think maybe I got hot?
If that was extra hot,
I'm very disappointed. All I'll say.
Little cocky there, buddy.
So, I got myself a bottle
of the Nando's Peri-Peri XX hot sauce,
and I too want to try the
spiciest level that they offer.
OK. Whoop, that might've been too much.
That's extra hot, huh?
No, not very strong.
I like the flavor a
lot on it, but – wait.
Hm, definitely manageable.
Yeah. I mean, like, I love
the flavor of all this stuff.
It's just not that hot.
[sneezes]
Now, for those of you who
think I got off lightly
and actually want to see me in pain,
you're in luck, because in the UK
we have an exclusive spice level
that goes above extra hot.
Here we have three chicken
wings coated in Vusa XX sauce,
which is one level above extra hot
on the Nando's Peri-ometer.
These already look hotter
than anything that was
in the roulette box.
There's lots of chili flakes
on them that are visible,
and it's just that kind of,
like, alarming red color
that if you see a snake that color,
you're supposed to run away from.
Cameraperson: Don't you just run
away from snakes in general?
Some snakes are friendly. [laughs]
Grass snakes. Grass snakes are cool.
And, of course, because I hate myself,
I'm going to try one of these.
They didn't give us gloves,
like they did in the Wingstop episode,
which I guess is a good sign?
I'm not great with spice,
so let's see how this goes.
Hm.
Bit of a slow burn.
Really slow burn.
Not really getting much
from this, I'll be honest.
Maybe if I just rub my eyes.
I'm not really getting it.
That's disappointing.
I, like I say, I'm not good with spice.
But I'm handling that with ease.
Nando's, come on.
It would have made for better content
if you made me cry, guys, so.
It's about the same as
what I got from there.
Y'all tried your really hot wings, right?
Well, I just wanted a
taste of the hot sauce
that they provided us with here.
If I can get it open at
any point in my life.
Hulk.
Nando's peri-peri sauce, hot. Gluten-free.
[coughs]
Excuse me.
Committing su–[laughs and coughs]
Cameraperson: Was it that hot?
No.
That's for the camera.
Cameraperson: What?!
[laughing]
I should get an Oscar.
[crowd cheers]
It was a little hot.
Cameraperson: OK.
But it wasn't, like,
too hot, like I'm dying.
Cameraperson: It's kinda spicy,
but this already has...
I did that to trick you.
Do you see how I became a double agent?
Cameraperson: Wow.
I actually did have a reaction.
Cameraperson: It's good though.
It's really sweet.
It just hits you in the throat.
It's like...[whacks throat]
Now, at the other end of
the heat scale from Vusa,
we have one more exclusive baste,
which is the Peri-Tamer.
This is described as mild and sweet,
and it's just for people
who don't really like spice.
And then finally we have something
that isn't technically chicken,
but more of a chicken replacement.
This is the Great Imitator wrap.
It contains imitation chicken
made from pea protein.
So, we have some exclusive
chicken items of our own, Harry.
We can get these chicken thigh skewers,
which come with red pepper and onions,
and they look salivating.
We can also get these chicken livers,
which you won't currently
find on the UK menu
due to the pandemic.
The Thigh and Mighty sandwich.
Then we can get a chicken
Caesar in the form of a wrap
or a pita bread.
Also got a lot of salad bowls,
and that you won't find in the UK.
There's a peri-peri chicken tender bowl,
an ancient grains bowl,
a chicken Caesar salad,
a tomato and Halloumi salad,
and chicken and avocado
and pepper roasted bowl,
and a cauliflower, butternut,
and Halloumi salad.
It's just, like, a lot of salad.
That's not my cup of tea.
This is my cup of tea.
We have two exclusive
appetizers in the UK.
Firstly, we have Halloumi
sticks with a chili jam dip,
and then we have some sweet potato wedges,
which are served with a garlic Perinaise.
I do not like sweet potato.
I wish people would stop
serving it on menus.
It is always worse than
chips and always costs more.
So, we only get the one
exclusive appetizer:
the garlic sticks.
On the side of your meal in the UK,
we have a few exclusive sides,
such as corn on the cob,
some long-stem broccoli,
spicy rice, and finally
we have some coleslaw.
Our exclusive sides are
a Caesar side salad,
Portuguese rice, winter roasted veggies,
butternut squash, and corn,
and braised brussels sprouts.
Now, in addition to the Vusa sauce,
we also have garlic
Perinaise, as I mentioned,
which comes with the sweet potato wedges,
and we have this one, which
is a peri barbecue sauce.
The only exclusive sauce we have
is a coconut lemon peri-peri sauce.
It would take a while to go through
all of the exclusive drinks,
so we're just going to
show you some highlights,
such as this.
This is a Gingerella, which
is an organic ginger ale.
Nix & Kix sparkling cucumber-mint drink
with a hint of cayenne.
And, of course, we have this one,
which is a Royal Flush kombucha.
Now, I personally like kombucha.
I know it's a little bit
divisive, but it's pretty good.
We can also get alcohol from a UK Nando's.
We've got some lager,
some pilsner, an IPA,
and a white wine.
La Croix, and Bundaberg ginger beer,
this Honest iced tea,
as well as a Mexican Coke,
which, throw me the bottle opener!
We also got alcohol too.
We got beer and wine.
We can get rose sangria
and spiked lemonade.
Nice.
And our only exclusive dessert option
is this Barely Baked brownie.
Let's finish out with the desserts.
In the UK, you can close out your meal
with a slice of Choc-A-Lot
cake, which is really good.
It's very moist.
With a slice of white chocolate
and raspberry cheesecake,
and finally a gooey caramel cheesecake.
I thought I'd have a crack at explaining
the whole "cheeky Nando's" phenomenon
to our viewers from across the pond.
If you were on the internet,
like, five or 10 years ago,
you've probably seen this phrase.
It just kind of refers to this time
where cheeky Nando's with the lads
was just the go-to activity.
It was like, mostly teenage
boys would go into town
for a day out, wander around the shops,
end up in Nando's, have a meal,
and then usually Instagram or Snapchat it
with the caption "cheeky
Nando's with the lads"
with this emoji.
I'm going to make that my
next Instagram caption.
Cheeky Nando's with the lads.
Clancy's my lad.
Come here, Clancy.
[laughs]
Cheeky Nando's with the lads!
["The Nando's Skank" plays]
Medha: Harry, you gotta bust a move more.
♪ Chicken ♪
Joe: Yeah, no thanks on
that, guys. Uh, no, thanks.
♪ And I love to sing ♪
That's quite enough of that.
[laughs]
♪ Chicken wings ♪
♪ They're my favorite thing ♪
♪ And I love to sing ♪
All right! Another "Food Wars" episode
where I did almost nothing.
I could get used to this.
[groans]